[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition and it's time to
take a stroll through zombie land with
the long-awaited sequel now making its
way to cinemas worldwide throughout this
video I'm going to be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the horror comedy as well as its ending
there's gonna be heavy spoilers here so
if you don't want anything about the
phone wound then I highly suggest that
you double tap out of the video right
now without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown of zombie
land at double-tapped
ok so zombie land double tap picks up a
full 10 years after the first film and
the sequel sees the return of the main
cast of characters from the zombie
franchise which is still made up of
Columbus Tallahassee Little Rock and
Wichita Columbus and Wichita are dating
and Tallahassee is sort of a father
figure to Little Rock this makes for a
dysfunctional group who've gotten by due
to their strict adherence to the rules
which up until this point has kept them
alive they're at a place now where
zombie killings sure has become easy but
what double-tap does differently to its
predecessor is that it shakes up the
formula a bit and introduces a new
evolved zombie named the t800 that is
basically the title of the Daft Punk
song harder better faster stronger in
addition to this there's a whole new
host of Walking Dead including the home
earth named after the infamous Simpson
character that's a dumb lumbering mess
Hawkins as in Stephen Hawkins who is the
complete opposite of the Homer and the
ninja silent but deadly all of these
really elevate the film and kickstart
the intro with an awesome reminder of
just how fun this franchise is I was
blown away from the start by just how
enjoyable the movie was and watching the
Columbia logo do some zombie killing
herself made me remember exactly why the
first film got such a cult following
anyway after making the white house
their new home they pardoned Wesley
Snipes settle down and truly become a
family in The Fast and the Furious sense
of the
Columbus decides to propose to Wichita
and makes things official but she
completely rebuff sit worried that all
marriages end in divorce and that their
new world simply isn't built for
attachment little rock dreams of going
off on her own
due to Tallahassee still treating her
like a child and together she and
Wichita leave on the road they me a new
traveler and then we pick up a couple of
weeks later where Columbus and
Tallahassee discover Madison a ditzy
survivor who somehow has managed to
survive the apocalypse with a lot of
dumb luck and by having no brains this
kind of sets up the aesthetic of the
film which centers around the group
meeting new characters that really bring
a lot to the dynamism of the movie
Columbus and Madison sleep together just
in time for which it had to return and
tell them that Little Rock is left for
Graceland with a wannabe rock star it's
an awesome way to change up the dynamics
of the film and I was worried that the
movie would feel stale after such a long
hiatus but there's just so much added
here that it feels fresh and
reinvigorating providing a much needed
shot in the arm for the franchise this
very much becomes a road trip set to the
backdrop of the zombie apocalypse and
for those who thought that zombie movies
were dead and buried this shows that
there's plenty of life left in the
estate on the road they come face to
face with the apex predator t800 that's
probably gonna be better than the new
Terminator film and end up having to
apparently kill Madison due to her
showing signs of zombification I'll get
into this later but after getting to
Graceland they meet a woman named Nevada
played by rosario Dawson who tells them
that the pair have headed to a commune
in Babylon which is built around a
skyscraper here in Tallahassee bond over
their shared love of Elvis and sleep
together and awaken the next day to find
two more survivors that are basically
mirror images of Columbus and
Tallahassee now my biggest problem with
these new editions of bar Madison is
that the characters don't really last
long each one is either dropped out of
the plot or taken out just as quickly as
they're introduced and I would have
loved to have been with the characters
long enough to actually gain an
attachment to them it kind of makes
these newbies feel a bit pointless and
though all of them get an awesome moment
each it's not enough to really make you
more invested in the film now there does
come some redemption when
rediscover Madison driving an ice cream
truck and we learned that a freak out
was actually just a reaction caused by a
neurology Columbus was supposed to kill
her in the woods but your boy is under
the thumb and it's like when the girl
that you think you blocked turns back up
to ruin your life again I'm just kidding
ladies I love you anyway they arrived at
Babylon and are forced to turn in their
guns which they but grudgingly do in
order to find Little Rock the commune
sets off fireworks to celebrate their
arrival the Little Rock implies to
Tallahassee that she wants to be her own
woman and he decides to part ways with
them on the road he comes across the
biggest zombie horde since World War Z
and heads back to warn Babylon that the
fireworks are attracting them left with
no weapons the group really struggled to
fight them off and it leads to an
amazing finale the Horde is absolutely
huge and makes for an awesome showdown
and when it seems like all hope is lost
Avada shows up and rescues them from
their fate allowing them to escape up
the skyscraper on the rooftop
Tallahassee runs off and grabs onto a
crane but the zombies blindly follow him
with most of them running off the edge
however to manage to get hold of him but
Little Rock saves him with a pistol at
she forgot to hand in at the border they
managed to pull Tallahassee back in and
save his life
in the end Wichita accepts Columbus's
hand in marriage and she finally says
yes to him Little Rock breaks things off
with a boyfriend who ends up getting
together with Madison and Nevada and
Tallahassee hook up joined by Nevada the
group decide to leave the commune and
after almost a decade of searching for
one Columbus states that they found
their home with one another staying at
home isn't a place it's the people here
with the film ends with a surprise
ending you with Bill Murray that was
shown in trailers for some reason and if
you're wondering exactly what that was
then we finally have the answers now
it's a kind of fourth wall breaking
thing but it has Murray promoting
Garfield 3 the flabby tabby in 2019 and
comparing it to the Godfather trilogy he
says he did the movie because drugs cost
money and it's a hilarious way to end
the film this takes place during Daisy
of the zombie outbreak and actually
follows what actions he took to end up
in the first film it's an awesome little
Easter egg that fans of the franchise
will love and
watching Murray go about killing zombies
and having fun with it is amazing we
also get another post credit scene
that's a blooper of Murray trying to cop
up a football that I thought I'd drop
into the video just in case you left the
film before you got to see it but what
did I think of the movie overall well
Dom Beal and double-tap is an awesome
addition and that one's a thing just
falls slightly short of the original is
still a great great ride the movie
perfectly balances comedy and action and
it's just a blast from start to finish
every character from the main cast gets
a chance to shine and no I do think that
the film under develops its new
additions those who want to just have a
catch up with a cast from the first film
will find a lot to like it is slightly
predictable on the whole but when you're
having this much fun who really cares
the team behind it did an awesome job of
recapturing the spirit of the first film
and a feels like we never really left
this with them not missing a beat
matching the original in both tone and
style this is definitely the one to
watch this weekend and I was worried
that interest would wane a lot in the
film with its prior entry being so long
ago however this really gets you back on
board and I really really hope it's not
another 10 years before we get to go
back to zombie land and see what other
adventures there are for the characters
zombie land is great as you can tell I
had a lot of fun with it and that's why
it gets a seven point five out of ten
just between us cost money didn't see
that coming
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on zombie land double tap so
make sure you drop them in the comment
section below if you enjoy this video
then please DoubleTap that like button
and then tap it again coz you've just
done liked it and make sure you check
out my ending explain breakdown of last
weekend's big movie El Camino which
would be linked at the end we go over
the entire film and discuss its ending
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on Twitter a
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
the description below we're also giving
away a free copy of the Marvel phase
three part one box out on blu-ray which
contains Civil War Doctor Strange
homecoming Ragnarok
more and all you have to do to be in
with the chance of winning is to like
this video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on Zombieland - in the comment section
below
the winners gonna be chosen on the 15th
of November and the set will be shipped
out from then to ever get surprised so
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is the channel for people who are
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you